.
Die ganze Welt sieht die Bilder,
was mit den Flüchtlingen
auf dem Meer passiert.
Alles, das auf diesen Bildern
sichtbar ist, haben wir erlebt.
Wir starben nur nicht.
Jeder Mensch ist auf seine Erde,
seine Stadt, seine Heimat stolz.
Wenn der Mensch nicht gezwungen ist,
flieht er nicht aus seiner Heimat.
Ich habe auf vieles verzichtet.
Alles, was ich in 58 Jahren
erarbeitet habe,
musste ich zurücklassen.
Wenn man hierherkommt,
fühlt man sich beengt,
sehr beengt.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Über viele Jahre
habe ich das politische Engagement
dieser Kurden
aus der Ferne mitverfolgt.
Ich bin selbst Kurde und lebe
seit drei Jahrzehnten in der Schweiz.
Die politischen Vorgänge
in meinem Herkunftsland
interessieren mich noch immer sehr.
Ich war überrascht, als ich erfuhr,
dass diese prominenten Männer,
die ich bis anhin
nur aus den Medien kannte,
heute als anerkannte Flüchtlinge
in der Schweiz leben.
Sie erzählen mir,
wie sie diesen abrupten Schnitt
in ihrer Biografie erlebten
und vor welchen Herausforderungen
sie nun stehen.
Firat und Özlem Anli leben in Bern.
Özlem ist Ärztin, Firat Jurist.
Bevor er vor drei Jahren
in die Schweiz kam,
war Firat Anli Oberbürgermeister
der Stadt Amed/Diyarbakir
mit rund 1,5 Mio. Einwohnern.
Ich wurde in Amed geboren.
Ich verbrachte mein ganzes Leben
in dieser Stadt.
Wir wohnten zur Miete
und in jedem Quartier der Stadt.
In der Altstadt,
innerhalb der Stadttore,
und im neuen Stadtteil.
Deshalb bin ich mit dieser Stadt
besonders vertraut.
Als Jurist habe ich in Amed
für NGOs gearbeitet.
Menschenrechtsvereine
und sonstige Organisationen,
die sich für die Rechte der
kurdischen Bevölkerung einsetzten.
Ich war für die Anwaltskammer
von Amed aktiv,
für Menschenrechtsvereine
und politische Parteien.
Im Jahr 2014 wurde Firat Anli
gemeinsam mit Gültan Kisanak
zum Co-Bürgermeister
der kurdischen Stadt Amed gewählt.
Das System der Doppelvertretung
von je einer Frau und einem Mann
in politischen Ämtern ist ein
Grundprinzip der kurdischen Bewegung.
Anli und Kisanak hatten grosse Pläne.
Doch nach drei Jahren im Amt
wurden die beiden von der Regierung
abgesetzt und verhaftet.
Anli verbrachte neun Monate
in Untersuchungshaft,
bevor er in die Schweiz flüchtete.
Seine Amtskollegin
ist noch immer inhaftiert.
Dort kannte ich 20'000 Menschen.
Das alles musste ich zurücklassen,
das ist mein grösster Verlust.
Heute kann ich
keinen mehr kontaktieren.
V.a. bist du fremd.
Was bedeutet das?
Ein fremdes Land,
eine fremde Gesellschaft,
eine fremde Sprache.
Ich war seit 1990 Biologielehrer
an verschiedenen Gymnasien
in der Provinz Ankara.
In der Türkei war es
Staatsangestellten verboten,
sich gewerkschaftlich
zu organisieren.
Im Jahr 1990 sagten wir,
dass wir aufgrund des internationa-
len Pakts de facto das Recht haben,
eine Gewerkschaft zu gründen.
Es gelang uns dann tatsächlich.
Ich war dann Lehrer, Aktivist
und Gewerkschaftsführer.
Lami Özgen hatte seit den 90er-Jahren
verschiedene einflussreiche Ämter
bei der Lehrergewerkschaft inne.
Zuletzt vertrat er als Co-Präsident
des Gewerkschaftsbunds KESK
die Anliegen von rund 240'000
Angestellten im öffentlichen Sektor.
Dass ein einflussreicher,
unerschrockener Gewerkschafter
sich gegen die Parolen
der Staatspolitik stellt,
missfiel den Machthabern
in der Türkei.
Lami Özgen wurde verfolgt
und sah sich schliesslich
zur Flucht gezwungen.
Seit 2017 lebt er in Bern.
Ich bin geschieden
und habe eine Tochter.
Sie ist kürzlich
21 Jahre alt geworden.
Sie studiert an der Universität.
Sie hat zunächst in Ankara studiert.
Wegen Problemen -
wegen meinen Problemen -
war es ihr nicht mehr möglich,
in der Türkei zu studieren.
Sie studiert seit letztem Oktober
an der Humboldt-Universität
in Berlin Chemie.
* Ruhige Klänge *
Wie viele Baklava?
Zwei, drei?
Doch nicht mit diesem Messer.
- Es geht schon.
Eins?
- Ja.
Nach meinem Pharmaziestudium
ging ich nach Varto.
1992 eröffnete ich dort
eine eigene Apotheke.
Im gleichen Jahr
fiel meine Schwester als Kämpferin
für die Kurdische Arbeiterpartei
in Van.
Daraufhin brachen die Behörden
die Arbeit mit mir ab,
mit der Begründung, ich sei
der Bruder einer Terroristin.
Ich bekam
finanzielle Schwierigkeiten.
Darum wanderte ich nach Antalya aus.
Nach zehn Jahren in Antalya
kehrte Demir Celik zurück
in seine Heimatstadt Varto
und kandidierte dort auf Wunsch der
Bevölkerung für das Bürgermeisteramt.
Nach einer Amtsperiode
als Bürgermeister
machte er in der
nationalen Politik von sich reden.
Er war Gründerpräsident der
linksliberalen kurdischen Partei BDP,
die bei den Parlamentswahlen 2011
grosse Erfolge verbuchte.
Demir Celik war bis 2015 Abgeordneter
im türkischen Nationalparlament.
Demir und Songül Celik leben seit
rund vier Jahren im Kanton Bern.
Vor Kurzem sind sie aufs Land
in die kleine Einliegerwohnung
im Haus eines kurdischen Freundes
gezogen.
Das Ehepaar hat zwei Söhne.
Einer von ihnen folgte ihnen
in die Schweiz und lebt in Bern.
Wie läuft es bei euch?
Es läuft. Deine Mutter und ich
necken uns gegenseitig.
Wir sind beschäftigt mit dem Garten.
Wir kommen zurecht.
Es geht nicht schlecht,
aber auch nicht besonders gut.
Als ich in die Schweiz kam,
gab es bei der Berufungsinstanz
13 hängige Urteile gegen mich.
Nachdem ich in die Schweiz
gekommen bin,
kamen immer mehr Verfahren hinzu.
Heute sind es 37 Strafverfahren.
In zwei dieser Verfahren wurde ich
nun rechtskräftig verurteilt.
Einmal sechs Jahre und drei Monate
und einmal drei Jahre.
Es steht eine Gefängnisstrafe
von neun Jahren und drei Monaten
gegen mich aus.
Wir haben geredet und unsere Meinung
zur Sprache gebracht.
Wir haben Vorschläge für die Lösung
der Kurdenfrage gemacht.
Sie sagen, das sei gemäss
der türkischen Verfassung
und den geltenden Gesetzen
verboten.
Die Regierung sagt,
der Massstab ist,
dass wir uns nur innerhalb der
türkischen Ideologie äussern dürfen.
Das akzeptierten wir nicht.
Wir machen Politik.
Es ist die Aufgabe der Politik,
Probleme zu lösen.
Ich habe in der Türkei
an der politischen Akademie
zu der Idee einer demokratischen
Selbstverwaltung unterrichtet.
Die Türkei
hat etwa 80 Mio. Einwohner.
In der Türkei leben nicht nur
Türken, sondern auch Araber,
Tscherkessen, Lasen, Kurden,
Jesiden, Asyrer, Muslime
sowie Christen.
Wir wollten, dass diese Vielfalt
von Völkern in Mesopotamien
und Anatolien anerkannt wird.
Wie wollten wir das erreichen?
In einem kantonalen System
wie in der Schweiz.
* Er spricht kurdisch. *
Das Buch
ist jetzt in der Türkei verboten.
Nun wirft mir der Staat vor,
ich hätte die Ideologie hinter
Selbstverwaltung und Städtekämpfen
durch die Veröffentlichung
meines Buches hervorgebracht.
Es ist eine neue Anklage
erhoben worden.
Wegen der Gefährdung
der Staatseinheit
fordert der Staat eine
lebenslängliche Gefängnisstrafe.
* Sie sprechen kurdisch. *
Wenn du deine Muttersprache
sprichst,
sagen sie, du dienst dem Terror.
Wenn du deinen Glauben lebst,
Wenn du in diesem Staat
nicht Türkin bist,
nicht muslimisch und von Konfession
Hanifitin, also Sunnitin,
Wenn du nicht die gleiche Denkweise
hast, dienst du dem Terror.
* Freizeichen *
(Frau) Hallo.
- Hallo, liebe Hivda, wie geht es?
Gut. Wie geht es dir?
Danke, es geht mir gut. Und dir?
Ja, mir geht es auch gut.
Wann beginnt dein zweites Semester?
Am 14. April
- April?
Normalerweise haben wir
von Ende Februar bis am 14. April
vorlesungsfreie Zeit.
Nach den Prüfungen
haben wir normalerweise Ferien.
Aber in den Ferien
habe ich drei Wochen Praktikum.
Praktikum?
- Ja.
Ja, in den Ferien
musst du hierher nach Bern kommen.
Ich werde kommen.
Ja, ja.
Tschau, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Bye bye.
Tschau, tschau.
Ich habe zweimal versucht,
zu fliehen.
Beim ersten Mal musste ich
auf halbem Weg kehrtmachen.
Das kleine Boot auf dem grossen Meer
kommt dir wie ein Stück Papier vor.
Mit uns auf dem Boot
waren Frauen und Kinder,
auch kleine Kinder.
Kinder -
obwohl die Eltern bei ihnen waren -
Kinder sind etwas Besonderes.
Die Schreie der Kinder
hinterlassen tiefe Spuren.
Dir gehen viele Gedanken
durch den Kopf.
Du denkst an den Tod.
Du denkst an dein früheres Leben.
Das Schwierigste ist,
dass du dich fragst,
warum du das
über dich ergehen lassen musst.
Der türkische Staat ist autoritär
und bereit, Gewalt anzuwenden.
In so einem Land muss man sich auch
für die Demokratie stark machen.
Das war schwierig.
Wir haben oft den Kopf hingehalten.
Wir wurden einige Male angegriffen.
Ich weiss gar nicht mehr,
wie viele Male wir verhaftet
und mit Knüppeln und Tränengas
angegriffen wurden.
Wenn du dich
für die Demokratie einsetzt
und dich gegen den schmutzigen Krieg
gegen die Kurden stellst
und dich für den Frieden
stark machst,
dann bist du immer
im Visier der Behörden.
Im Jahr 2009 ...
Das Jahr 2009 ist für die Geschichte
der Türkei wichtig.
In diesem Jahr gingen die Behörden
gegen kurdische Politiker,
Gewerkschafter und Journalisten vor.
Immer wieder wurden die Leute
verhaftet und angeklagt.
Auch wir, die Funktionäre
des Gewerkschaftsbundes KESK,
wurden verhaftet.
Die Aktivitäten unserer Gewerkschaft
wurden kriminalisiert.
Lami Özgen kam zunächst für sechs-
einhalb Monate in Untersuchungshaft
und wurde schliesslich
zu einer Gefängnisstrafe
von über sechs Jahren verurteilt.
Er sowie Tausende weitere
demokratische Politiker/-innen
wurden im Rahmen des sog.
KCK-Prozesses der Mitgliedschaft
bei der verbotenen Kurdischen
Arbeiterpartei beschuldigt.
Ziel dieser fingierten Anklagen
war die Ausschaltung der
demokratischen kurdischen Opposition.
Mutmasslich fiel sie dem Machtkampf
zwischen der von der Gülen-Bewegung
kontrollierten türkischen Justiz
und Erdogans Regierung zum Opfer.
Bittere Tatsache ist,
dass der türkische Staat
diese Menschen teils jahrelang
in Untersuchungshaft festhielt.
Glaub mir, manchmal
komme ich auch durcheinander,
wie oft ich in Haft war -
vier- oder fünfmal.
1995 wurde ich verhaftet,
auch 1996 in Ankara,
1997 wurde ein Haftbefehl erlassen.
2009 wurde ich verhaftet.
Gemeinsam mit Hunderten,
Tausenden anderen
war ich wegen des KCK-Prozesses
lange Zeit in Haft.
2013 wurde ich freigelassen,
2016 aber schon wieder inhaftiert.
Ich war zehn Monate in Haft,
wurde freigelassen.
Zwei Tage später gab es schon
einen neuen Haftbefehl.
Dieser steht immer noch aus.
Zuletzt richteten sich die Anklagen
gegen meine Arbeit
als Bürgermeister.
Alles, was wir für unser Volk
und unsere Stadt taten,
wurde als eine Straftat betrachtet.
Sie fragten:
"Warum habt ihr das System der
Co-Bürgermeisterschaft eingeführt?"
Dieses System
wurde als Straftat eingestuft.
Am Tag der kurdischen Sprache
hielt ich eine Rede.
Sie sagten, das sei eine Straftat.
In der letzten Anklage wurden mir
und meiner Kollegin Frau Kisanak
ausschliesslich Reden vorgeworfen!
Das war die Neujahrsfeier
Newroz 2016.
Millionen Menschen kamen zusammen.
Frau Kisanak und ich
begrüssten die Leute.
Es war keine Rede mit politischem
Inhalt, es war nur eine Begrüssung.
In der Anklage wurde das
als eine Straftat betrachtet.
Sie folgerten daraus die Mitglied-
schaft einer illegalen Organisation.
Aber es ist nichts Strafbares daran.
Ich bin selbst Jurist und ich weiss,
was ich sagen darf und was nicht.
Du kannst es 100-mal anschauen.
Es ist unmöglich,
etwas Strafbares darin zu finden.
Liebe Mitbürger,
hier, an der Newroz-Feier
in der Hauptstadt Kurdistans,
zollen wir den Gefallenen Kobanês
und den Gefallenen unseres Volkes
unseren Respekt.
Wir verneigen uns
vor den Gefallenen Kurdistans.
Wir versprechen,
dass sie in unserem Leben
und in unserem Streben,
immer lebendig bleiben.
Millionen Kurden versammelten sich.
Das zog weltweit
Aufmerksamkeit auf sich.
Das störte und ärgerte sie
eigentlich.
Im Herbst 2016 wurden Firat Anli
und Gültan Kisanak
in einer Nacht- und Nebelaktion
verhaftet.
In der Stadt
brachen heftige Proteste aus.
Die Staatsanwaltschaft forderte
eine lebenslängliche Gefängnisstrafe
für Firat Anli.
Die Anklage lautete
wieder auf Mitgliedschaft
oder gar Führung der bewaffneten
Kurdischen Arbeiterpartei.
Ich frage Firat Anli,
was an diesen Vorwürfen dran ist.
In Bezug auf meine Rede
am Newroz-Fest behaupten sie:
Murat Karayilan hat das Volk Kurdis-
tans zur Newroz-Feier aufgerufen.
Du bist dem Aufruf gefolgt -
damit bist du Teil der Organisation.
Ich habe weder Gewalt befürwortet,
noch Gewalt angewendet.
Noch werde ich mich
jemals dazu herablassen.
Ich war einmal Bürgermeister.
Ich hätte Anrecht auf eine Dienst-
waffe gehabt - das wollte ich nicht.
Als ich Mitglied
des Nationalparlaments war,
hätte ich Anrecht auf eine Dienst-
waffe gehabt - ich wollte das nicht.
Eine Waffe ist für mich etwas
Kaltes, es ist wie eine Schlange.
Ich weiss nicht,
ob ich über diese Vorwürfe gegen uns
lachen oder weinen soll.
Es ist so seltsam.
Es ist gleichzeitig die Komödie und
die Tragödie des türkischen Staates,
der türkischen Justiz.
Während Firat Anlis Amtszeit
als Oberbürgermeister
kam es zu einer Freundschaftsbrücke
zwischen den Städten Zürich und Amed,
welche einen grossen Symbolwert
für die kurdische Bevölkerung,
sowohl in der Schweiz,
als auch in der Türkei, hatte.
In diesem Rahmen besuchten Anli
und seine Amtskollegin Gültan Kisanak
im Herbst 2016 Zürich.
Bei dieser Gelegenheit trafen sie
auch Stadtpräsidentin Corine Mauch.
Guten Tag.
- Guten Tag, Frau Mauch.
Herzlich willkommen!
- Vielen Dank.
Oh, das ist sehr nett,
ganz herzlichen Dank, wunderschön.
Wie geht es Ihnen?
- Danke. Und Ihnen?
Sie leben in der Schweiz,
ich höre, Sie sprechen Deutsch.
Ja, ein bisschen.
Aber ich muss lernen ...
Sie lernen. Sehr schön.
Ich habe eine starke Erinnerung
an Ihren
und Frau Kisanaks Besuch hier.
Ich möchte Sie fragen,
wie geht es Frau Kisanak?
Ich übergebe Ihnen ein Dossier
mit den neusten Informationen
zu ihrer Situation.
Vor vier Jahren
haben Frau Kisanak und ich
uns hier mit Ihnen über
die aktuelle Situation unterhalten.
Es freute uns sehr, was wir
in Zürich erfuhren und sahen.
Diese Erfahrungen wollten
wir in Amed/Diyarbakir umsetzen.
Doch leider hat sich dieser Wunsch
nicht erfüllt.
Wir wurden drei Wochen
nach unserer Rückkehr verhaftet.
Frau Kisanak ist seit vier Jahren
im Gefängnis von Kocaeli,
1'000 km von Diyarbakir entfernt.
Frau Kisanak ist bei den Kurden
und in der Türkei sehr bekannt.
Für ihren Einsatz für die Rechte
der Frauen hat sie teuer bezahlt.
Wir hoffen sehr, dass sie
ihre Freiheit bald zurück hat.
Wie haben uns natürlich überlegt,
wie wir sie unterstützen können.
Ich habe mich persönlich
an Frau Kisanak gewandt,
um ihr die Solidarität unsererseits
zu zeigen.
Auch, dass sie nicht allein ist.
Ich stelle mir vor,
dass man gar nicht mehr weiss,
ob überhaupt noch jemand
an einen denkt.
Dass wir in Gedanken bei ihr sind.
Sie antwortete mir,
dass das für sie sehr wichtig war.
Ich habe grossen Respekt davor.
Damals spürte ich schon, dass
Sie unter sehr schwierigen Umständen
für Ihre Werte und Ziele
einstehen müssen.
Und die Verhaftung hat gezeigt,
dass Sie wirklich ernsthafte
persönliche Risiken eingehen,
um das zu tun.
Das verlangt mir grossen Respekt ab.
Ich wünsche Ihnen alles Gute.
Grüssen Sie bitte unbekannterweise
Ihre Frau und Ihre Kinder von mir.
Dass demokratisch gewählte
Bürgermeister einfach abgesetzt
und verhaftet werden,
hat in der Türkei System.
Zwar lässt der Staat Wahlen zu,
respektiert dann jedoch
den Volksentscheid nicht,
wenn die Wahl auf einen nicht
regierungstreuen Kandidaten fällt.
Im März 2019 wurden Adnan Selçuk
Mizrakli und Hülya Alökmen
mit überwältigender Mehrheit ins
Bürgermeisteramt von Amed gewählt.
Bereits wenige Monate nach
Amtsantritt wurden sie abgesetzt.
Beide befinden sich
noch immer in Haft.
Dass die Politik
sich die Justiz als Instrument der
Unterdrückung oppositioneller Stimmen
zunutze macht,
ist schon lange Thema in der Türkei.
Diese Willkür zerstört Leben.
All meine Protagonisten mussten
dies am eigenen Leib erfahren.
Der Vorsitzende des Gerichts
in Izmir, das uns verurteilte,
hatte sich
gegen das Urteil gestellt.
Unsere Aktivitäten
seien gewerkschaftlich
und demokratisch gewesen.
Sie dürften
nicht kriminalisiert werden.
Er hat damit gegen die beiden
anderen Richter argumentiert,
die ihm unterstellt waren.
Die Verurteilung
war damals eine Staatspolitik.
Diese beiden Richter handelten
im Auftrag des Justizministeriums.
Sie kamen nach Izmir, nahmen
an einer einzigen Verhandlung teil
und fällten das Urteil.
In St. Gallen trifft Lami Özgen
seinen Rechtsvertreter
Serif Altunakar,
der ihn in der Schweiz
vom ersten Moment an begleitet hat.
Serif kam selber in den 80er-Jahren
als Flüchtling in die Schweiz
und studierte in Fribourg Jura.
Er kennt die Rechtssysteme
beider Länder.
Ich stellte fest,
dass er aufgrund
eines konstruierten
Sachverhalts verurteilt wurde.
Ihm wurde die Mitgliedschaft
in einer terroristischen
Organisation vorgeworfen,
was überhaupt nicht zutrifft.
So ein Urteil
wäre in der Schweiz nicht zulässig.
Warum?
Weil es den Grundprinzipien
eines Rechtsstaates widerspricht.
Ein Putschversuch im Juli 2016
veränderte die Machtverhältnisse
in der Türkei schlagartig.
Erdogan beschuldigte Gülen
als Drahtzieher
und ging hart gegen die mutmasslichen
Mitglieder seiner Bewegung vor.
Von der folgenden Verhaftungswelle
waren auch hochrangige Mitglieder
des Gülen-Netzwerks
in der türkischen Justiz betroffen.
Trotz allem wurde das
umstrittene Urteil gegen Lami Özgen
2017 vom Obersten Gerichtshof
bestätigt.
Die beiden Richter wurden entlassen
und verhaftet mit dem Vorwurf,
dass sie Mitglieder
einer illegalen Organisation seien.
Sie sind noch im Gefängnis.
Um den Zustand
der effektiven Unterdrückung
der kurdischen politischen Bewegung
zu erhalten,
setzt der Staat enorme Kräfte ein.
Dabei ist es noch nicht lange her,
dass ein anderer Weg möglich schien,
der die Hoffnung auf eine
friedliche Lösung aufblühen liess.
Im Jahr 2013 liess Erdogans Regierung
einen Weisenrat bilden -
über 60 bekannte Intellektuelle,
darunter auch Lami Özgen,
sollten das Land bereisen,
um die Meinung der Bevölkerung
zur politischen Lösung
des jahrhundertealten Kurdenproblems
zu hören.
Zu dieser Zeit
kam etwas Gutes zustande.
Es begannen Gespräche
zwischen dem Staat
und der kurdischen Bewegung
für Friedensbemühungen.
Das war eine neue Entwicklung,
eine Sache,
die nie zuvor dagewesen war.
Nachdem Erdogan jedoch im Sommer 2015
mit den ultranationalistischen
Kräften der Türkei
ein Bündnis eingegangen war,
um seine Macht zu erhalten,
fiel der Weisenrat in Ungnade.
Lami Özgen vermutet,
dass die neuen Staatskräfte
die Aufkündigung
der Friedensgespräche
mit der erstarkten
kurdischen Bewegung
zu einer Bedingung
ihrer Unterstützung machten.
Zu Hause zeigt mir Lami Özgen
Einladungen,
die er während seiner Zeit als
Gewerkschaftspräsident erhielt.
Es sind grosse Namen:
vom türkischen Staatspräsidenten
bis zur Schweizer Botschaft
in Ankara.
Welche Bedeutung hat die Bekanntheit
von damals für ihn heute noch?
Ein kurdisches Sprichwort sagt:
"Die Welt dreht sich."
"Mal bist du oben
und mal bist du unten."
Özlem Anli und ihre beiden Kinder
im Alter von elf und 15 Jahren
durften erst im August 2019 -
zwei Jahre nach Firat Anlis Flucht -
in die Schweiz einreisen.
Für die Familie begann endlich
wieder ein gemeinsamer Alltag -
gezeichnet von der Herausforderung,
in einem fremden Land
ein neues Leben zu beginnen.
(Özlem) Peymans Lehrerin
hat ihm gesagt,
dass sie weiss,
dass er noch nicht alles versteht,
es aber sicher bald lernen wird.
Das hat ihm gutgetan
und ihn motiviert.
Er ist froh, dass man Verständnis
für seine Situation hat.
Er ist auch froh, dass sie merkt,
wie sehr er sich bemüht.
(Firat) Im Vergleich zum letzten
Jahr geht's ihm jetzt besser.
Er hat sich gut eingelebt.
(Özlem) Letztes Jahr musste er
noch keine Prüfungen machen,
dieses Jahr aber schon.
Und je mehr Freunde er findet,
desto wohler wird er sich fühlen.
Es ist sehr schwierig,
eine neue Sprache
und ein neues System kennenzulernen.
Ein neues Leben aufzubauen.
Die Familie muss
all diese Schwierigkeiten mittragen
und das lässt einen verzweifeln.
Oft kam mein Sohn von der Schule
nach Hause und weinte.
Er sagte: "Ich bin kein Depp,
ich bin nicht dumm."
Er verstehe die Sprache
einfach nicht
und er wisse nicht,
was die Lehrer sagen.
Wir haben heute im Sportunterricht
Übungen mit dem Basketball gemacht.
Danach haben wir die Geschichte
aus einem Buch nachgespielt.
Deshalb habe ich Legos
mit in die Schule genommen.
Das haben wir heute gemacht.
Wie viele Figuren hattest du?
- Fünf.
(Özlem) Mein Eindruck ist,
dass du seit Beginn des Schuljahrs
besser verstehst.
Ja, das stimmt, ich
verstehe Berndeutsch jetzt besser.
Ich werde in der Schule
auch unterstützt.
Kürzlich hatten wir einen kleinen
Test und das lief gut.
Die Artikel im Akkusativ:
der, die, das.
Wie verändern sich diese Artikel
im Akkusativ?
Diesen Fehler mache ich am meisten.
Im Akkusativ verändert
sich nur der maskuline Artikel der.
Die und das bleiben unverändert.
Was die Sprache angeht,
bist du stumm.
Wenn die Leute dich etwas fragen,
bist du taub.
Du bist wirklich wie taub.
Du verstehst einfach nichts.
Zudem bist du weit weg
von deiner Familie,
deinen Freunden,
deiner Heimat.
Auch der Kampf, den du geführt hast,
ist stehen geblieben.
(Frau) So, Lami, du darfst anfangen.
Wo?
"Wo..."
Genau.
"Worüber haben Sie sich
in letzter Zeit richtig geärgert?"
Genau, worüber haben Sie sich
in letzter Zeit geärgert.
Waren Sie schon einmal auf etwas
oder auf jemanden neidisch?
Neidisch auf, stolz auf, wütend auf.
Ich gebe mir grosse Mühe,
aber die deutsche Sprache
ist sehr komplex und reich.
Ich habe B2 abgeschlossen
und jetzt mit C1 begonnen.
Warum haben wir einmal worauf
und einmal auf wen?
Auf wen für die Personen,
worauf für die Sachen.
Sehr gut, wunderbar.
Manchmal brauchen wir
diesen Unterschied.
Was die Arbeitsintegration betrifft:
Ich habe ja einen Beruf.
Biologie
ist auf der ganzen Welt anerkannt.
Wenn ich die Sprache
gut genug sprechen könnte,
hätte ich als Biologe
viele Arbeitsmöglichkeiten.
Auch wenn es schwierig ist,
werde ich es schaffen.
So sehe ich es.
* Sanfte Zitherklänge *
Hier musst du
wieder von null anfangen.
Im Alter von 40, 50 Jahren
musst du ein neues Leben beginnen,
nach allem,
was man bis anhin erarbeitet hat.
Tatsächlich liebe ich meinen Beruf.
Aber ihn hier wieder aufzunehmen,
scheint sehr schwierig zu sein.
Aber wir haben Hoffnung,
dass meine Frau, die Ärztin ist,
irgendwann in ihrem Beruf
hier arbeiten kann.
Sie hat über 20 Jahre
als Ärztin gearbeitet
und hat viel Erfahrung.
Wir wollen uns so schnell
wie möglich mit unseren Fähigkeiten
in die Gesellschaft einbringen.
Wir haben die Heimat zurückgelassen.
Wir mussten weg.
Wir haben unser Dorf zurückgelassen,
unser Haus.
Auch wenn wir dort
nicht reich waren,
waren wir immerhin unabhängig.
Hier sind wir
auf den Staat angewiesen.
Die Schweiz ist ein demokratisches
Land mit schöner Natur,
aber es ist nicht unsere Heimat.
In Demir und Songüls Trauer
um ihre Heimat
mischt sich auch die Sorge
um den zweiten Sohn Heval.
Im Jahr 2013 schloss er sich
den bewaffneten Truppen
der Kurdischen Arbeiterpartei an.
Wir sagten ihm:
"Du studierst Jura."
"Werde Anwalt und setze dich so
für die Demokratie ein."
Er sagte: "Das reicht mir nicht."
"Du bist Politiker, warst Apotheker,
Bürgermeister, Parteipräsident
und Abgeordneter."
"Was hast du erreicht?"
"Die Kurdenfrage ist nicht gelöst."
Ich vermisse meinen Sohn sehr,
wie jede Mutter das tun würde.
Keine Mutter wünscht sich,
dass ihr Sohn stirbt,
selbst wenn er glaubt,
sich für etwas Gerechtes
einzusetzen.
Jahrelang hofften die Eltern
auf ein Lebenszeichen ihres Sohnes.
Dann, im Oktober 2020,
berichten türkische Medien
über seine Festnahme.
Doch die Eltern können
keinen Kontakt zu ihm aufnehmen.
Seit Lami Özgen in der Schweiz ist,
pflegt er auch Kontakte
zu den hiesigen Gewerkschaften
und verfolgt deren Arbeit
mit grossem Interesse.
Den Erfahrungsaustausch
mit den Kollegen schätzt er sehr.
Wie geht es dir?
- Gut, und dir?
Danke, es geht mir gut.
- Wunderbar.
Hallo, Lami.
Wie geht's?
- Danke, es geht mir gut.
Lami hat in diesen
drei Jahren relativ viel gelernt.
Nicht nur die Sprache, er hat auch
die Gewerkschaften kennengelernt,
die Diplomatiekulturen
der Gewerkschaften und Parteien.
Er hat alles gut gemeistert.
Du warst in der Türkei
eine sehr bekannte
politische Persönlichkeit.
Wie erlebst du das?
Mal ganz oben, jetzt ganz unten,
wie ist das für dich?
In der Türkei
muss man nicht nur
als Gewerkschaftler kämpfen,
sondern auch als Demokratiekämpfer,
Friedenskämpfer,
als Kämpfer
für gesellschaftlichen Probleme.
30 Jahre lang
haben wir so viel gemacht.
Aber hier in der Schweiz gibt es
für mich nicht so viele Aktivitäten.
Ich habe verschiedene Kontakte
mit Gewerkschaften,
politischen Parteien
und verschiedenen Plattformen.
Aber nicht wie in der Türkei.
Ja, manchmal fühle ich mich gut,
manchmal fühle ich mich
leider nicht gut.
Die Erlebnisse in der Türkei
haben bei Lami Özgen
tiefe Spuren hinterlassen.
Er zeigt mir Bilder
von einem Anschlag 2015,
der das ganze Land erschütterte.
Lami selbst war mittendrin.
* Sirenen, Schreie *
Wir waren mitten in Ankara,
doch die Ambulanz
liess 30 Min. auf sich warten.
Die Ambulanz
wurde einfach nicht geschickt.
Die Ambulanz wurde behindert.
Viele Schwerverletzte wurden
mit Taxis ins Spital gebracht.
Wir haben sie mit Taxis
ins Spital geschickt.
Die Ambulanz
kam erst 30 Min. später.
Der Gewerkschaftsbund KESK und drei
weitere bedeutende Berufsverbände
organisierten im Oktober 2015
eine Friedenskundgebung in Ankara,
nachdem es
nach drei Jahren relativer Ruhe
wieder zu schweren
bewaffneten Kämpfen gekommen war.
Über 100'000 Menschen kamen zusammen
und forderten ein Ende der Gewalt.
Ein durch den Islamischen Staat
verübter Anschlag
auf die friedliche Kundgebung
forderte 103 Tote
und über 500 Verletzte.
Lami Özgen macht den türkischen Staat
direkt für den Anschlag
verantwortlich.
Inzwischen kam alles heraus.
Dass der Geheimdienst und der Staat
von diesem Anschlag wussten.
Die Täter wurden unterstützt,
weisst du?
Als wir das am Anfang sagten,
akzeptierten sie es nicht.
Später belegten es ihre eigenen
Untersuchungsbeauftragten
in ihren Berichten.
Sie verhinderten den Anschlag
bewusst nicht.
Weil es ihnen
für die bevorstehenden Wahlen 2015
einen Vorteil verschaffte.
Mit diesem Anschlag wollten sie
die Opposition einschüchtern.
Weil so viele Menschen kamen,
liefen wir 100 m weiter vorne.
Hätten wir das nicht getan,
wären wir
anstelle der anderen gestorben.
Wir überlebten,
aber an unserer Stelle
starben unsere Freunde.
Wenn ich die Bilder
von diesem Massaker wieder sehe ...
Die Bilder haben immer noch
grosse Auswirkung auf mich.
Es ist jedes Mal,
als würde ich es von Neuem erleben.
Ich weiss,
dass ich keine Schuld habe.
Aber wir werden dieses Massaker
nicht vergessen.
Ich werde es nie vergessen.
Auch an Firat Anli sind die
Erlebnisse der vergangenen Jahrzehnte
nicht spurlos vorübergegangen.
Der Tod seines engen Freundes
und Weggefährten Tahir Elçi
bewegt ihn noch heute zutiefst.
Tahir Elçi war Vorsitzender
der Anwaltskammer in Diyarbakir
und über Jahrzehnte
eine Schlüsselfigur
in der Menschenrechtsbewegung
in der Türkei.
Er wurde mehrmals verhaftet
und mehrmals schwer gefoltert.
Aber Tahir gab nie auf.
Tahir Elçi war ein Pionier,
der viele Verfahren
vor den Europäischen
Menschenrechtsgerichtshof brachte.
Er hat Hunderte Verfahren
dorthin gebracht.
Während andere Angst hatten,
ihre Unterschrift
unter eine Akte zu setzen,
ging Tahir in Kurdistan
von Dorf zu Dorf
und bot sich als Verteidiger an.
An jenem Tag war ich
bei einer Buchvernissage,
bei der es um die historische Brücke
mit zehn Toren
über den Fluss Tigris ging.
Das war mein Programm
an jenem Samstagmorgen.
Ich war etwas ungeduldig,
denn eigentlich
wollte ich Tahir anrufen.
Ich spreche zum ersten Mal darüber.
Tahir Elçi gab im November 2015
vor einem historischen Minarett
in Diyarbakir -
das in den Tagen zuvor
mutwillig beschädigt worden war -,
eine Presseerklärung ab,
in der er das Ende der Gewalt
in den kurdischen Gebieten forderte.
Noch während seiner Ansprache
wurde er von einer Kugel getroffen,
die in einem Feuergefecht
zwischen der Polizei
und einer PKK-nahen Jugend-
organisation abgegeben worden war.
Ich hörte plötzlich Schüsse.
Ich rief Tahir an.
Aber ein anderer nahm ab.
Ein Journalist rief mich an.
Er sagte,
es gebe schlechte Nachrichten.
Ich ging ins Leichenschauhaus.
Ich sah Tahir auf dem Tisch liegen.
Ich umarmte ihn.
Ich sah,
wie seine Stirn noch blutete.
Ich weiss nicht,
ob es Polizisten waren,
die noch im Raum waren.
Ich schickte sie weg.
Dann weinte ich.
Ich liess niemanden zu ihm.
Ich umarmte ihn sehr lange.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Songül und Demir Celik haben
zahlreiche Verwandte und Freunde,
die ihre Heimat schon Jahre zuvor
verlassen mussten
und nun verstreut
in Westeuropa leben.
Zu diesen pflegen sie
enge Kontakte.
Heute laden Songül und Demir
zu einem gemeinsamen Essen ein.
Meine Neffen haben mich
von Beginn an unterstützt.
Ich musste keinen einzigen Tag
in einer Asylunterkunft verbringen.
Zweifellos war mein Onkel
nicht nur in der Familie,
sondern in der ganzen Region
eine bekannte Persönlichkeit.
Wie kann er als Flüchtling
einen Neuanfang machen?
Es macht einen traurig,
so etwas zu sehen.
Es hätte nicht
so weit kommen dürfen.
Aber kaum war mein Onkel hier,
begann er mit voller Energie,
Deutsch zu lernen.
Diszipliniert sass er dafür
jeden Tag 1 Std. am Computer.
Danke, Frau Celik
- Bitte schön.
Es ist unsere Kultur.
Wir wollen zusammenkommen.
Darum haben wir heute Gäste.
Wir wollen unsere Beziehungen
warmhalten,
da wir weit weg von der Heimat sind.
Wir wollen,
dass sich unsere Kinder kennen.
So geht die Kultur nicht verloren.
Liebe Damen und Herren, willkommen!
Bitte lasst uns gemeinsam essen.
Guten Appetit.
* Sanfte Zitherklänge *
Lami Özgen und Firat Anli
kennen sich seit Jahrzehnten.
Ihre politische Arbeit
war von derselben Vision geprägt -
ein demokratisches und
freiheitliches Land mitzugestalten.
Auch wenn der Preis für ihr
politisches Engagement sehr hoch war,
ist ihre Vision immer noch lebendig.
In der Schweiz sehen sie viele Dinge,
die sie in ihrer Heimat
gerne umsetzen würden.
Z.B. ein Netz
touristischer Wanderwege.
Stell dir vor,
z.B. im Landkreis Pasur.
Ich hatte
schon etliche Projekte im Kopf.
Nur leider hat der Krieg
nicht aufgehört.
Am Berg Andok und Dorschin
gibt es viele geeignete Orte.
Butter, Käse, Brot ...
Es gibt geeignete Berge.
Der Berg Andok ist zum Skifahren
fantastisch geeignet
und im Sommer und Herbst
kann man dort wandern.
Du kannst dich sicher
auch noch erinnern,
vor 1980 kamen Touristen nach Amed.
Vor der Grossen Moschee und vor
der Kirche parkten Touristenbusse.
Nach dem Militärputsch 1980
kam auf einmal niemand mehr.
Weil die Region
militarisiert worden war.
Wir arbeiteten drei, vier Jahre,
um die Stadtmauer von Amed
und die Hevsel-Gärten
in das UNESCO-Weltkulturerbe
aufnehmen zu lassen.
Es gibt noch Tausende
solcher Kulturstätten,
die noch nicht entdeckt wurden.
Danke dir.
Guten Appetit.
Danke fürs Kochen.
Wie geht es deiner Tochter
in Berlin?
Letzten Freitag hat sie
die Semesterexamen beendet.
Sehr gut.
- Sehr schön.
Super.
Nur in organischer Chemie ...
Nicht gut, nicht schlecht,
aber nicht gut, normal.
Alle anderen Fächer
hat sie gut bestanden.
Sehr schön.
Aber sie hat alles bestanden?
- Ja.
Ich habe die Schweizer Gesellschaft
etwas kennengelernt.
Ich habe Freunde
in der Schweiz gefunden
und finde immer mehr.
Montagabend mit Lami,
das war Tradition.
Wir haben ein bisschen weniger
für das B2 gemacht.
Aber dafür uns
sehr gut kennengelernt.
Ich habe eine Freundschaft gewonnen,
keine Lehrer-Schüler-Beziehung,
sondern wirklich eine Freundschaft.
Es ist atemberaubend, wenn du
erzählst, was du durchgemacht hast.
Dein Lebenslauf.
Für diese Freundschaft
bin ich dankbar.
Ja, danke.
- Danke dir.
Songül Celik
trifft im Haus der Kulturen in Bern
ihre Verwandten und Freunde.
Alle sind aktive Mitglieder
des Kulturvereins Dergah.
Heute wird die jährliche
Cem-Zeremonie gefeiert,
zu der Menschen aus
der ganzen Schweiz angereist sind.
* Traditioneller Gesang *
Unser Kerzenlicht
ist für die Hoffnung,
dass alle Menschen auf der Welt
in Frieden und frei leben können.
Songül Celik
ist es ein grosses Anliegen,
die kurdisch-alevitische Kultur -
sie nennt sie Raa Haq,
den Weg der Wahrheit -
auch hier in der Schweiz zu pflegen.
Sie betont die Gleichberechtigung
in ihrer Kultur
und möchte den Naturglauben,
der stark von Gesang,
Tanz und Dichtung geprägt ist,
mit einem modernen Religions-
verständnis in Einklang bringen.
* Ruhige Gitarrenklänge *
Wenn ich hier in die Berge fahre,
kommt mir meine Jugend in den Sinn.
Das Schönste war, dass man frei und
mitten in der Natur war - wie hier.
Die Natur gibt mir Kraft.
Diese Pflanze gibt es überall,
auch in Kurdistan.
Es gibt zwei-
und dreiblättrige Arten.
Die dreiblättrigen sind ein wichtig-
er Nahrungsbestandteil für Schafe,
weil sie
einen hohen Proteingehalt haben.
* Traditionelle, kurdische Klänge *
Ich frage Lami Özgen, ob die Schweiz
je seine Heimat werden kann.
Man sagt ja: "Jede Pflanze
wächst auf ihren eigenen Wurzeln",
weisst du?
Als ich hierherkam,
war ich 55 Jahre alt.
Für meinen Alltag
kann die Schweiz eine Heimat werden,
aber für eine wirkliche Heimat
ist es schwierig.
Meine Wurzeln sind nicht hier.
Meine Wurzeln, meine Erde sind dort,
meine Erde ist Kurdistan.
Dort hast du eine Identität,
einen Status,
deinen Platz in der Gesellschaft.
Freunde in Amed sagen mir,
dass wir es sehr gut haben.
"Ihr lebt
in diesem schönen Land Schweiz,
mitten im Paradies auf Erden."
Ich habe hier Freunde
und kann ein neues Leben beginnen.
Aber wenn ich die Möglichkeit hätte,
würde ich keine Minute
länger hierbleiben.
* Sanfte Klänge *
SWISS TXT / Access Services
Michaela Hoss - 2021